This episode of Your Mom's house is
brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that
provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Christina.
Okay. We just restarted everything. Todd.
Christine, your mom's house. Um,
cast Tom cast and it was really low.
That's why
Tom, what's your Pronoun Today? Uh,
feel Kinda Zimmy I
guess. Gemzar yeah. Zay.
No, not say I'm filling
traditional. Hers. She,
oh, that's rare. Yeah. You don't
get that a lot. That's very rare.
I Dunno. It depends on how
this episode goes. I could,
I could fluctuate. You could.
Ooh,
Dylan, Dylan, Dylan, where are you going
to be? You had a great weekend and man,
Diego,
I did so many mommy's came out,
so thank you for everybody who went to
the House of bruise on a Saturday night.
Super Fun. So moving along, fill her up.
Delphia I added a second
show at the nine 45 show.
There's some tickets left on that,
like a filler up.
Delphia gets your show
your tickets to that one.
And then December 8th Grammer
seat theater sold out late show.
We're gone.
It's all gone almost.
I think there's like 20 tickets left
on the leadx show and then January 10th
here in Hollywood at the comedy store.
I'm doing the main room January 31st
through 2nd of February. Denver,
Colorado at the comedy works.
February 28th through March 2nd Madison,
Wisconsin at the comedy
club on state that an April,
I'm doing mini apple tits at acme and
then, uh, May 10th and 11th to Tempe,
Arizona, Tempe, Tempe. A lot
of people ask me about Arizona.
I'm doing Tempe at the Improv and then
June 20th through 22nd Washington,
Dick come January. It's June, sorry.
June. I said Tyree Washington.
Dick. Yeah. It's pretty
Christina p online.
All right. Um, that's great.
I can finally tell you this.
People have asked me and I believe me,
I have,
I've been the one trying
to find out the most, uh,
the Welmont show,
the Belmont theater show in Montclair,
New Jersey that I had to postpone
due to a sudden snow storm,
uh,
has been rescheduled.
The new date is Wednesday,
February 13th.
So it's official.
I like that.
I'm on Facebook now and we are going to
do that show Wednesday, February 13th.
Anybody who had tickets to
the show that was postponed,
the tickets will be honored at this show.
If you are not able to attend the February
13th show or no longer wish to attend
the show, you can get a full
refund at your point of purchase.
So there's that.
Um,
that means that there'll probably be
become a few tickets available since some
people won't be able to go to the
new day. It's now February 13th, um,
man for and disco. I should
tell you that the, uh,
the show that was added
January 4th is getting close.
We're not going to add a third.
So if you wanted to come to San Francisco
show at the May Sonic January 4th,
this would be the time to get it.
And the one other thing I can tell you
besides telling you that all the new and
2019 shows are at Thomson [inaudible] dot
com is we added a show in Nashville at
the Ryman Auditorium, the first
show, February, or excuse me,
April 14th sold out.
There's a few single tickets left,
but it's essentially a sellout.
So we added a late show
April 14th in Nashville,
Tennessee at the Ryman.
I'm very excited to go there.
Thanks for getting those tickets
and thanks for wearing your jeans.
So high and tight.
Yeah.
Mama, Mama, Mama, Mama, Jean.
Let's get into it. Got a big show. Lots of
do. Lots of talk about ready. I'm ready.
Maybe put your phone down.
It's time to go to work.
We don't have time to like just text.
All right.
No, we're not ready. Alrighty.
I'm listening to you.
Okay. But I mean, you know,
here we go.
If you want to do it.
Just spoke to Ashley and besides that
he said you were a class play in and you
let them alive in the first session.
He said that it will smelly on the stage.
I thought he had shut. Sorry. I
thought where's that factor then stage.
Did they
don't bring anyone in loving come in
to your mom's house.
He's looked professional darts.
Oh, is this what that is? Yeah,
that's pretty funny. He say, Hey,
look like he farted and
[inaudible] himself and like,
I think darts are the only
sport where they'd like be like,
let's keep talking about it. Yeah. What'd
you think? What'd you say? And he's like,
yeah, yeah, he did fart on stage. Yeah.
Well darts are crazy because
they put them in pubs,
which is probably the worst place you
could throw around sharp objects is when
people are drinking,
drinking heavily. It's crazy.
You can really not give a fuck about
your overall fee. I mean, look at this.
This guy is probably one of the best
in the world at this. Sure. Good. Um,
it looks like hot shit.
Same with baseball players look
good either. That's true. Baseball,
you can really let yourself go. Especially
if you're a pitcher or first basement.
You can really let yourself go. But
they do have to run in baseball. Yeah.
At times.
Certain puzzle.
It was funny that there are certain
positions where you kind of don't have to,
you know, like if you're a pitcher, you
never going to run through a catcher.
You don't have to run
really no first baseman.
You're never running during the game.
I mean during, when you're on diff,
like maybe if you are batting, obviously
you have to run around the bases,
but there's guys that just,
yeah,
they're just huge and out of shape
and they're good at baseball.
It's kind of this, you can, this is,
you can be far less happening. Yeah.
And be world class and look like this.
I mean this is a tournament. No,
this guy is not, you know, horrible.
But I'm saying you wouldn't see this guy
and go probably world class athlete of
some kind. No, no.
Just spiritual Wesley.
And besides that you said you were a
class play and you let them alive in the
first session.
He said that it will smell on the stage.
I thought he had shut. Sorry. I thought,
what is that factor then? Stage today.
Good day. Good day. Who the
fuck is watching darts? Man,
that's what you really got to ask.
I'm in.
It is one of those things
where if you've ever,
everyone's usually had at least a
go at throwing a dart. I've done it.
I've done it 10 times. Sure. I never like
was obsessed with it. And then when you,
you know, when you throw a
good one you're like Whoa,
but you feel like it's by chance.
Yeah.
And then ever we usually has a friend
that is actually kind of proficient and
you go wow, like you can actually
hit where you're aiming. Sure. Wild.
But then these guys really
are just unbelievable at it.
Are they, are they, are they just
drunks like these guys hanging out?
Why can't you be both?
Yeah, that's a good point.
And that is really the benefit of
being a professional dark player. Yeah.
You can be an alcoholic and a
professional athlete at the same time.
I want to see if he keeps talking about
shitting cause I think he might. Yeah.
No, no. I think he thinks
you did it. You compete.
If I ended up large, they'll be more smell
there. I thought he had shut and I. Dot.
T but this bad. What was
bad? Most think Catholicism.
This is a pro level interview. He said
you could put your finger up my ass.
No smell there.
You wish all starts.
If it football players were this
kind of stuff. I'd watch football.
I've talked about this for years.
I talked about how I would pay
so much money, so much money.
Really if they were like we're going to,
you can pay to hear the on field
mic on during the whole game.
Right. Like a pay per view extra.
Yeah. I would pay for that too.
Cause that would be, that's
the amount. Yeah Dude,
I'm writing the check
immediately. Seriously fucking
bitch. All that trash talk.
Ah, I don't, you know, but they have
to protect their wholesome image,
which is the Horse Shit. It's the,
it's due. I know. Violent fucking game.
We have bunch of slack.
Dicks.
That's why I liked rex Ryan so much
cause he was always talking so many big
words. There's a lot of big words
between the player. Yeah, of course.
I really like, what's the big word? Well
I'll just let you guess, but this here,
this is no,
well I think he thinks you did
it. You compete. If I ended up,
laughs there'll be more snow. Yeah. I
thought he had shut and I'm like stop to,
it was bad. It was bad. It
was bad. It was a stone.
Catholicism and they started putting bet.
I bet it must have knew that
to get so on Monday. Yeah.
What? What was the last part?
I'm going to spin something.
A window open the window. Is that
what he said? He went away to,
oh it was bad. It was us. Thank
Catholicism and they started putting bet.
I'll bet most of you
the tickets on Monday.
Oh you started playing better. You must
have needed to get some wind out. Yeah.
Yeah.
I liked that.
The interviewer feels the need to discuss
the FARC clarify things cause he's
saying you farted and he's like,
put your finger up my ass.
There's no smell there. Yeah,
that's fine. Better than you did.
Look how happy he is. He's like, yeah,
he farted and he started playing better.
We'll see.
That's the thing about life and then the
representation of life on television.
Like why can't we just discuss
the guy that the guy farted,
it's not a big deal but your card you
right. But the NFL and then they're like,
well, we can't, we have a whole summit.
Well, it's this whole delusion stupid,
isn't it? Because you know
people at home are farting.
Everyone's talking to everyone at home
has been like when they watch like
football games here and there going like,
oh,
I'd love to hear what that guy
just said right there. Of course.
And they're sitting there guessing.
They're probably saying like, oh,
he probably told him to
suck his fucking Dick. Yeah,
that's what they're saying
at home, you know? But you're
like, no, no, no, no, no, no.
We can't sell Buick ads if we do that.
No. Well that's because there's a,
there's a level of human out there
that's in, in denial about real life too.
Like they don't want to know that far.
It's exists on real things of that nature,
which is bizarre to me.
And he thought it was you or no, hands
up scaling my kid's life, so help me God,
nothing closed when it was smelly anyway,
it was smelly.
She'll just shit myself.
But you know that love towards you
in a documentary and scared to F it.
It smelled like that. I put
my hands up Google. Oh, sorry.
Yeah, that's great. Is that they're still
discussing the fart. Yeah. And he's still,
and he's saying, oh, going on. I'm
not ashamed to admit. Yeah, I do that.
I would have said I farted there.
Sure. But let's see. Sorry.
And he thought it was you. Oh No. Hands
up. Just get on my kid's life. So help me.
God, nothing closed anyway. It was smelly.
Usually have half out and still
just shit myself, you know,
like love towards you in a documentary.
Scared to f five five that
smelled like that. I put my
hands up the war. Oh, sorry.
That's great. It's great. Yeah, it's just,
just became my new favorite professional.
We got to follow darts.
Well don't tell me you will
not see. Boy, he's up there.
So I'll definitely keep the
was the other day and it was,
I was eggs rotten eggs.
Not from you. Not from me.
No, no, no. Okay. Thank you. And I be
telling me walk past it was a wife.
They're rotten eggs.
That's why I was thinking of some,
we're still discussing this year.
He's so sincere.
I figured this is what this
would be like Joey Diaz.
It'd be like if he was like professional.
Yeah.
I know at any of this he would be going
interviews about like you smell that
shit during the match. That wasn't me dog.
I would have told you I fucking fired.
Yeah, he would totally be
like that. Unreal man. Yeah.
I feel like it has to do with dark,
the world of darts and also
that they have a better,
they're more comfortable
with talking about, you know,
they're not so serious over
there. Yeah. I mean, oddly enough,
because the high society is very
serial. They're not high. Listen,
if you're and in darts, you're hanging
out in bars, but it's pub culture.
That's why these guys hang out in bars.
Get hammered and throw a throw needles
around. Yeah. Yeah. I will smell it.
Yeah. It's like watching shuffleboard
though. It's gotta be so God damn boring.
Yeah. It shuffleboard
professional. They're probably,
there's probably a pro level
of a, of everything. Well,
the at the dark guys will
actually, I mean, we're not
planning for like, you know,
NBA, NFL money, but they'll actually
make money in these terms. Sure. No,
the only thing more boring is that
curling at the Canadians do, I mean,
what the fuck is that? Even if it's
an Olympic event, you can be list.
So boring. What are we watching
the hockey puck going? No,
that's horrible. That is so fucking
boring. It's sweeping, right?
It's how fast you can sweep. Well,
you, you, they shut, you know,
somebody pushes it and then the people
sweep the ice right in front of it.
But then you also want it to stop in a
certain place, you know? Yeah. One knock.
That next motherfucker's out I think
too. Oh, okay. So it's like Shuffleboard,
I guess. Oh, nice.
That was how it was. Eggs. Rotten eggs.
Yeah.
Farts.
I had so many last night. We're just
coming out of Thanksgiving week. Yeah.
And that's a far,
it's all week.
It's probably the hardiest
weaken America for sure.
Imagine all the farts in
shifts have happened. I know.
And then this morning I made Brown
and I had the two I shed to shower at,
cause normally I rely on the
toto to clean up the remnants.
But there was so much of a
schmear on the toilet paper.
It was like a Hershey kiss
was melted in there and I,
I just knew that I needed
soap and water the day I did.
I was telling you that. Yeah.
But I still get the leaky,
but it's like a never
ending wipe that caused it.
Mediterranean. Mediterranean. Yeah.
And then we had sausage last night,
like the, I'm sorry, the salaams right.
So processed meats on top
of Mediterranean. I did a
late night t j run. Yeah,
late night, but late for
the clock friends. Yeah. No,
it was like stepping back in time.
For some reason I didn't even
know there was one nearby.
They do a bad job of like
the sign is not even in,
they're very upset with their lack
of proper signage. I'm serious.
It's like it's tucked away. I
know. Even if you'd put the,
put the navigation on it tells you
to go off a side street to go into,
I mean it's just, it's weird. But
anyway, that used to be our spot.
Um, when we lived in
silver lake many years ago,
we had a TJ on our street, like a block
we could walk to it. And that was,
we lived at trader Joe Traders,
Joe Joe,
and then there was the same cheese
next door. Yeah, on Hyperion.
And that was great too.
Cheese store spend a lot of spend money.
We did not have it. Oh for sure.
But it felt like, you know,
seeing the old treats there, I was like,
oh, this is like a flashback. Tried that.
As Joe has an, especially, I
liked the seasonal items too.
They got that gingerbread
house you can make now.
My favorite are those Italian squares,
the chocolate wafer squares.
They did not have those lines out here.
Know the guy was like,
I don't even know what you're
talking about. I'm like,
do not fucking work at trader's Joe.
I couldn't believe it.
And then I liked their pursuits.
The German for judo. I booed out.
We got to get your Gouda wheel.
I got to tell you each fan of that.
Good at really good prices,
Buddy Eddie Pepitone who was like,
yeah,
but five bags of stuff for $100. It's
true though. It's true. It is true.
I asked for a wine recommendation and
the guy knows his stuff and he's telling
him, you know, regions and this and that,
and he goes, this is a really good bottle.
It's got these notes, and
I was like, okay. I go, you
know, I'm not that particular,
but he's like, oh, you know,
when my cousin got married,
we actually brought a case of these and
it was, it's amazing. It's great wine.
I said, all right. It was, it's
like seven bucks. It was crazy.
You know what I really liked there?
The freeze dried strawberries, fever.
I had gotten a pouch full of those fro
freezing and frozen dried strawberries.
I have not.
The thing is they're just strawberries,
but they're prepared like astronaut
food, so they're crunchy. It's just fun.
It's like a silly way to each or your
bra stories. It was was a good time.
Now I also like,
they're dried apricots and,
and you know those give me intense farts.
They do.
I always like to leave when I know
you're going to have dried apricot or I
encourage you to eat them when I'm out
of town and those will make me shit.
Oh yeah, they will make you shit. What
makes you shit? Ah, so many things.
Fried foods make me shit back. That's
diarrhea. That's not really a farter.
It's like just, it's straight to seven.
That's what I call it. Take a bite guard.
This is a straight to seven.
That's just anything fried is what
you're saying. It's just really,
it's bad.
You ever shower after you don't like me
or you just let them a day? There's days.
Yeah.
I mean like I like,
I like to see if I can handle everything
with the bad day. I'll do two a day.
Full washes. You Know Tim? Yeah. But if
I'm doing, if it's a leaky, I'm like,
what's going on? And then I wipe
again. It's still a smear. I'm like,
I gotta take a shower. It bothers
me. How come though? And I'm
sure it's very serious
scientific question.
How come when you have like
a mushy wipe? Okay. Yeah,
but how come when I wash
it out with soap and water,
it stops the leaky. But, but let's
just say I just do a washlet,
but I do a thorough wash. It's not the
same. Why does, it doesn't make sense.
It doesn't make sense. I
agree. It doesn't make sense.
I'm being sincere. I'm being
sincere in the medical community.
Tell me why the soap and the wash does
a more thorough job. It stops the leaky,
but right in its tracks.
It's a great question. I'm
serious. It's a great question.
There are doctors that listen
unbelievable, so they can,
the question she's asking is how come?
You know what?
I think it might have something to do
with though standing up for a while.
There's a theory, you know? Like
my dad used to tell me, he's like,
sometimes she does stand up, let
everything fall back into place. Right.
Because when you sit down,
everything's kind of gate opens.
That's a really good
point. Yeah. Wait a minute,
you're telling me it's not the soap and
the water in the wash that's doing it,
but that rather I am standing in,
my muscles are kind of going back and I'm,
I'm interesting. It's all going
back. Wow. Now speaking of,
but topics, we had a guest
over at our home, um,
who is a physician's assistant and we
were getting to hear some cool stories
about working in an er as
a physician's assistant.
And this person was telling us that they
saw a lot of things in people's butts a
lot that it's, it never
stops. Isn't that funny?
A Plastic Cup.
How do you even get a cup
in your button in this case,
this guy just happened to stumble,
right Andrea.
But sometimes people put them in there.
Do you know how stupid I was?
Cause she made that
joke. She was like, oh,
he just fell out on the ha and I
was like, really? That can happen.
Like I totally didn't. And
you're being sincere. Why would,
but that's like a cop. Why would you put
a cup in your button? Like a Red One?
I like the color makes a difference.
It's like a type of,
I dunno, it'd be you just got us. I
just what's around and you're like,
I want something in my ass and you
finish. Well, I'm not using this anymore.
I want her a cycle. I don't want to throw
one of your favorite segments here. Uh,
drugs or mental illness.
Here we go.
I don't care.
Hmm.
I got you.
No Bitch.
You fucking bitch.
Hmm.
Ain't nobody got 10,000 artists like me.
What's your theory?
Got a video. Well, look,
apparently that's a porn star. Oh, is
that right? That's what it says here.
What do you think? Drugs
or mental illness. She's a
porn star and a rapper. Hmm.
Oh, there's another clip of
her hitting her boyfriend
and that Jesus.
God. Well, I'll tell you what the,
the time of day, it's broad daylight.
I don't think that matters. I guess
people do drugs all day long. Yeah.
She's really heated though.
That's not a normal,
it's in the eyes and those eyes tell you
crazy. I'm going to go mental illness.
Yeah. I think less drugs. More rage. More,
more emotion.
I'm going to go mental
illness coupled with drugs.
Maybe you're saying both a little
bit about little bit of everything.
The thing is they're
usually not far apart.
They usually like to hang out
together, so could be, um,
okay.
I tell you something. I was
thinking right here. Hmm. Um,
safety issue.
Good point.
She's wearing stilettos standing
on a drain cover and there's just,
there's holes in it. And I'm
really worried about safety.
Yeah, I wouldn't do that.
And I'm seeing maybe a Tib fib
fracture happening. Kid Fib. Yup.
Tip Fib could just go like that if
she takes a wrong stuff. I mean, look,
what would she do that? Look
at this one. This one's,
it's right there on the edge right
there. I know. I'm nervous about it. I'm,
I'm sitting here like,
you're going to get hurt to nail biter.
That's really not good to stand like
that now. But this is her video.
She might need to pair up with Nicole.
Can that man,
I tell you what's offensive about
this video already. She goes, bitch,
I'm Heidi flies. But let me tell you
something about Heidi Fleiss. Yeah,
that bitch is a fucking genius. Well,
that's why she's saying it. Yeah.
But she ain't know Heidi Fleiss.
But I mean she just a how Heidi
was the ho she was the, the pimp.
You know what I'm saying? Yeah. She's
a smart lady. Oh, manager. Yeah. No,
this bitch can we say
wow.
Wow.
Hollywood man and bitch strip.
Yes.
Politics, politicians, shit.
Hollywood. Madam Bitch.
Thank Hilda policy.
I don't like machine.
Please don't rush me.
I think one of the things
she should invest in is, um,
maybe some other mix,
some of the not the highest quality audio
production value is deduction of low.
Yeah. But then again, it might be
your first song. You never know.
Somewhere la thirst million.
Four months,
a hundred back the night.
Count this money.
Hi. Nice to me.
I know you want to thank
me by really ready.
I think too, again, I got to
say I'm a big fan. I'm not,
I'm not good at rapping. Yeah. Even I
know that her tempo is not right. Like,
she's not keeping up with
the, Oh, you're saying,
you're saying just like the pacing,
the pacing is off. And she said, yeah,
you want to get money. You know
what? I get it then it's, it's off.
Right. You know, but it's also, I
mean, you remember your first set,
you know what I mean?
It's gotta get you gotta work at it,
but I think you want to discourage anyone.
I don't want to discourage anybody art,
but I think she needs a little help
with the tempo and the pace today.
Yeah. She's the shit though.
You know what I mean?
But you have to have some kind of native
timing. Yeah. Native sense of timing,
right? Like, yeah, it's intuitive.
I assume somebody's got 10,000
artists like me. Actually,
a lot of people have
$10,000. It's all right. Um,
let's see if she's really saying it's
$10,000 seem low to you for a pair of
boobs. I mean, I, that seems
really cheap to me for tits.
Um, yeah. I don't know. Let's
see. I'm looking up her, uh,
her porno category. Oh, okay. What, what
kind of stuff does she do? All right,
here's some descriptions. What do you,
wait, let me guess first. I'm going to go,
she's, she's does the interracial
lot of black guys stuff like black.
I'm going to go for just, just judging
by her demeanor, what I've seen.
I'm going to go for, um,
interracial gang bang,
like the five black guys on her kind
of thing. She's this. All right.
Well here's some descriptions. Okay. Is
it just the scene description? Go ahead.
Okay. All right. Uh,
Belarus riding a cock while her girlfriend
watches a busty Bella Reese plump
Posi Slam from behind. Okay.
Sounds pretty vanilla heart.
Bella Reese gets pounded by her ebony
lover. Okay. You were right there. Okay.
Um, Bella Reese gets her big
ass ready for an ass. Fuck.
So she does anal.
She's kind of all over the place.
I don't see her specializing in it
shows a lot of these are actually anal.
Valerie's gets her tied.
Asshole assaulted Bella begging for a dig,
pounding up, harass the,
seems like maybe she's, um,
he uses her butthole lot.
She's anal girl. Yeah. Um,
it looks like I wouldn't have guessed
that. I wouldn't have guessed that. Oh,
it looks like she fucked her trainer
at the gym. I didn't know that.
So I was here. Oh, but Italian Bay bell
Reese takes on a black monster cock. Yeah.
She likes black eyes or her boyfriend.
Is that right? That was her boyfriend,
individual.
Um,
and then it just says Bella
Reese with a dude camping, uh,
and she fucks his big cock. What else
would, it's funny that they would do,
they would let you know that that's what
she does. She fucks the big cock. Yeah,
right. Yeah. Well there you go. Wow.
I don't get fired. Yeah, she looks like
she does. I'm definitely does it for real.
However, I would say that if
I were an adult entertainer,
that I would try to make songs too. I
feel like you would a good marketing tool,
like if she was decent at
it and if you're good at it,
it could be a real thing would be if
she was a porn star that could wrap.
That'd be kind of,
or imagine if like you were,
if you actually started selling
album stuff, here's the thing,
but you didn't quit porn. See all the
time whenever it was, whenever, uh,
the other stuff takes off
for the porn person, they're
like, aw, I'm stomping porn.
But if you kept doing porn, that's
what I mean. That'd be hard. Cool. Rad.
That'd be some g shit right
there. Yeah. She'd sell so many.
I'm more of everything. I want to get to
this before we have to take our break.
We have a guest coming in a little while,
but it was so popular this past week
showing it was just out of control.
Uh, there are more. Good
Morning Julia submissions.
Can I tell you that I can't get enough?
And I watched it when I
was away over the weekend.
Even shows that can't stop.
I can't stop watching Joe.
Uh, good morning Julia. Um,
I haven't really watched our submissions
from last week. That's what I'm saying.
So funny. The guy with the
fans was fucking amazing. I
have not seen any of these.
Just a heads up.
I have nothing to any of these blue band.
Put these in a folder for me.
So I'm,
I'm seeing these for the first time
just like you are just like Christina is
okay and jewelry is Jacob
[inaudible] they can forget
about that exit years
and I just,
I just know we're going to have a good
time together and go full throttle.
And uh, this is where I were.
I put all the plumbing is
every
type of man you're dealing with.
Look at that thing. I just, I
hope to hear back from you too,
baby. Three day, full throttle.
You know what that guy really captured.
I'd like the fan work. I liked the dirt.
The movement. The eyes. Yeah. His
intense relentless eye contact.
Yeah. Cause you notice the Joe really a
seductive, comforting thing for a one C,
right? Like when a woman, when
a man, yeah, break or blink,
it's relentless and they,
I think he captured the essence of Joe,
this guy because of the, the
relentlessness of the icon. By the way,
the Real Julia, we've been in
contact, we've been trying,
she has a job that doesn't allow her
to, um, always match our schedule.
But we continue to stay in contact and
we're still fingers crossed for possibly
next week.
I can't believe she's not making your
mom's house podcast her priority. I know,
I know. She really should be. I can
quit that job and take our call.
Juliet, here's faith Saul
important. Good Morning Julia.
I just wanted to tell you that again,
this bend my anniversary
with you the other day.
It was one of the greatest
moments of my life. Anyway,
I'll, uh, I'll hop off here,
but have a good day baby. Ciao.
Yeah, she spent her anniversary
with Julia did. Yeah. Yeah.
Oh my God. I love the way she got it.
[inaudible] submission. I love it.
And she nailed his accent and the
creepiness of the look. Very nice.
Nailed it.
One Julia and more fans meet Joe Swayla.
You know these fans go full throttle.
He's got the accent down. Perfect.
Yes. Who is this? This is a Chris.
Good morning,
Julia. I'm so excited.
I can hardly contain it.
I don't know if you recognize this,
but I'm in your class
is fixing your bed frame
almost some restraints and uh,
I heard you coming in through the
front door. They're terrified.
Kudos. Ah, this a lot of stuff.
I could be fixing your class.
I was asleep.
I can't wait to call end of that.
What?
You're so fucking full
trial when I get in that bed
second.
Yeah,
it was gray listening. Oh
my God. It's a ski mask.
Dan. Hey Julia. She all this,
all this built all this myself.
Every flake, every leaf. I built it
all and I'll build it for you Julia.
It's the kiss now really makes me,
it makes my stomach turn weird.
This is so weird.
What do you think Joe's doing?
Do you think he's commit suicide yet of
all those horrible mess and I don't want
them to know. Neither do I, but I'm just
saying he's got it. Where is Joe? Yeah,
we had a talk to him, figure
out his life. Did he? Uh,
he told this is the type of guy you get.
Oh, so fortune. Let's make it happen.
Let's make it happen. Wow. Oh Wow.
Wow, wow. Ciao baby. Kiss is like, uh,
no. Good. And here's Darren.
Good morning,
Julia.
Just work to show you by a basement.
I took it completely with my bare hands
to the ground as though it all for you,
Julia. I want you to see this because
you'll be spending less time down here.
Julie. I love you. You're my flower.
You're my pressures about every day.
Oh,
okay.
Go full throttle down here
in the basement, Julia.
Well, you know what I like about
this one? The suit, the suit.
I feel like this, this is a
biggest departure from this
dude's real personality.
Thinks. I was thinking, do you
like about this? Is that this guy?
This is really stepping out for him.
Do this.
Could be like a an attorney or
something like that. In real. Yeah.
Somebody is going to be like high fashion
defendant court and you're doing good
morning Julia videos.
Good Morning Julia and my everything.
And I have to say that Tom and I
have started texting each other.
Good Morning Juliet.
And that's what we say to each other
now and the other one wakes up.
It's pretty great. It's taken over
the house and taking over our lives.
I got to get going.
I got to go pick up Skeeto me ain't
you may say is tease me a you.
Yeah, I got it right. Maybe
how before leftover two liter of
diet coke I figured are trying to do,
um,
a remake of my two liter noper
chuckling challenge video.
Oh, okay. Okay. No burped.
Chugging. I didn't know that
was a challenge. Number one.
Challenge. Number two help
you can do it. I'm so, I have,
as far as his tender hooks,
this guy's drinking
a fucking two leader of Coke's Miro.
Oh my God. No, don't form. It's almost,
yeah, it's crazy. What is
he doing that's gotten,
that's not good for you last
night? He's a crazy person. Oh,
he's going to throw up.
Oh,
that's not real.
I Dunno.
I think it is.
That's her baby burps burps so big
like this kid. I saved that for you.
I was going to play
that right at the break.
Oh
God.
Thanks. You know, you like this.
Okay.
I like that. It's like a booger burp.
Okay. We're back after multiple breaks.
Um, we are joined by our guests, comedian,
improviser, actor. I want to make sure
I get it right. Right. Kahleel shake
Mohammed. Yeah, no problem. Most people
can't pronounce it is as well that you do.
Thank you so much.
Tsa Does it pretty well.
We'll shake it. No, it's
the great Faheem Mars
here and he has before.
I don't want to get too far away from it.
Well tonight if you're listening. Oh, it's
coming out tomorrow. No, you're wrong.
You're right. It comes out tonight and
audio and tomorrow on video, so yeah,
let's just say Wednesday, right?
Tuesday to Tuesday. Sorry.
That's okay. Tuesday and they'll
replay it and everything, but yeah,
just so people know,
it's a one off sketch special one hour
sketch comedy special called goat face.
Goats face. Yeah. It's with Hassan Minhaj
from daily show was on Patriot Act.
Now me, Aristotle, theorists,
and also folly. We did Youtube
starts way back in the day. Wow.
Sounds like a lot of enemy on that.
A little darker than most
of the programming I watch.
I'm ended not too dark.
Oh no, that's right. Yeah.
Yeah. We're, we're somewhere
in between. Yeah. Yoga Gateway.
Yeah. Like you look like you
were, I dunno, in Hawaii for
the week. It works for me,
but I do tell people that this is
much easier than explaining what that
explaining my, my more, my
parents were born here. You're
like, I'm going to Hawaii.
Yeah.
The big one,
big one is from Afghanistan.
Just, you know, which I
don't, I've never really met.
I've, well, besides his parents are
black. My bloods from there, dude.
Yeah. But he's from here.
He's from Seattle. That's
the Afghanistan of America,
right? He's from our Africanas. I don't,
I don't know nothing.
All the bumper stickers.
I'm trying to think of where the
actual Afghanistan of Americas.
There's definitely not a
Seattle. I love Seattle. No.
Um, let me ask you this.
Um, so when you were,
I imagine that there's
actually probably a,
I'm guessing a big Afghan
maybe population. I'm no,
actually, no. Yeah, no, really.
That's
why I think I am the way I am. Just
a warn, a ton of Afghans. I mean,
growing up some, you know, when I
would see other Afghans and stuff,
like there's a bigger population in
Orange County, I would say Virginia,
a Fremont, California, the bay area.
Those are kind of like Ed's fascinating,
um,
hotbeds of certain cultures in places
you don't imagine in the United States.
That's what I feel like. One of them
shows up somewhere and they're just like,
hey everybody, it's true.
Three months where it's at.
I was always fascinated by the number of
retrains and Ethiopians in Minneapolis
for this enormous population. They
go to Minneapolis and DC. Why?
I don't fucking know. I think there's
just such a network there already. Yeah.
It just makes it easier to kind
of like Cleveland Hungarians,
Polex chicargo Hungarians
Polacks ballet Hungarian.
That's right. That's right. A
lot of roofs skis out here too.
A lot of those brewskies treat like you're
family. You're like, come over here.
Come stay with her. Then why did they pick
Seattle if there wasn't a big hot bed?
Dad was finishing up university and they
were about four and says it said it was
going to do the versus I was going
to. Yeah. Or like what is the disco?
Just certain words. Did
you do university? Yeah.
And then did he finish university now? He
did it. Yeah. He said to here in America.
Okay, I'm so bad at this. I
should key cause it came twice.
He came in North Dakota and Minnesota,
I don't know which is which.
So he's finishing up his engineering
degree and then Boeing came by because
they're trying to do recruitment
and they had a brochure of Seattle.
And so my mom and my dad are
looking at this brochure brochure.
This is all they know about Seattle.
They see the space needle and they're
like looks good. Yeah. So yeah,
they had out to Seattle.
Now do you have the hat and your house
and I we were talking about earlier the
actual, the Afghan hat. It's
somewhere in a closet somewhere. Yeah.
Cause Hungarians,
we always have a horse hair canteen.
Hang that in the hallway and then like
a horn, there's a certain the hallmarks.
What would it be if you're
American and other country?
Would it just be like an Apple Pie Tin?
Cozy Kid rock CD? Yeah, totally.
I know what's American.
Oh like that would just like
telegraph American letterman's jacket.
Yeah, definitely. Um,
you know what the like a
lot of like foreigners,
at least I have South American foreign,
you know a blood and family.
So I would go down there a lot.
They always thought James Dean,
the look of a white tee shirt
and jeans screamed American.
So sometimes now we always go like,
Oh God,
I don't want to seem American anywhere.
But in certain times like if you were
going to discotheque right and to America,
you would put that on and they would be
like, then you were like exotic. Right?
So they were like white tee
shirt, blue jeans. They're like,
this is American girl jeans,
blue
jeans screams American.
I like sometimes sometimes you'll catch a,
like my parents or aunts and stuff,
we'll,
we'll watch like a
Bollywood satellite channel.
So you get to see like a little snips
of Bollywood videos and you get to see
like their version of what
they think America is.
Like the jeans and the
sunglasses and the shirts.
Like ed hardy hit five years later.
I always liked seeing another country's
version of what they think of marijuana.
It's cause it was always a little
off, a little, a lot of the world.
It has to be at hardy a lot
of that as far like America.
You had a beautiful American shirt.
Yeah.
Now you seem to assimilate to our
culture well, which is why you're here.
Did you have an immersion program?
It's really hard to beat it out.
Is it actually more waterboarded
on like did you have a hardcore,
um, African like upbringing though
or no, my parents were pretty chill.
I mean obviously I culturally I do have
that background and baggage a little bit.
It's tough when we were
talking about it outside. Oh,
when you're first generation you kind of
have the burden of trying to uphold the
old traditions.
But then you're also very American too,
so you're kind of torn between the two.
But there wasn't this crazy pressure like,
you know,
pray five times a day and blah blah blah.
And there was no, you're not Christian.
Oh fuck. Well this was fun.
God don't touch anything.
I said, I'm sorry. Um, so, but they
were praying five times a day or no, no.
My mom would pray every, every now and
then it stuff. But they would instill,
they would kind of,
now that I'm an adult,
I kind of realized it was just sort of
like rocket fuel does they give their
kids like, all right, I did my part.
Yeah. You know, I can't say that I did it.
A flogging yourself and everything.
No, we were pretty well to do.
We had somebody to do that for
the engineered ourselves.
Did you dad pray? No,
he didn't have, uh, no. My Dad
has even more moderate than wow.
He's listening. Like, will you stop
telling people that shit? Yeah.
Tell him I beat you guys
and I'll tell you. Yeah,
he threw keys in my head one time.
I left the garage door open. Yeah,
he just barged into the my bedroom
and we live in like a really,
really nice neighborhood.
There's this woods,
there's deer maybe would break in at best,
you know?
And I left the door open on accident cause
it's garbage day and then I just wake
up to my dad being like,
you left the door open and he tries to
like hit me and then I dodged him and I'm
surprised that I talked to him and I
went downstairs but I guess he just threw
his keys to the last second I hit the back
of my head. Did you cry? Be Honest? No,
but I just like how that, he was good
with that. Like once the keys at my head,
he wasn't staying anymore. He's just
like, all right, satisfied emotionally.
Didn't fuck with you at all.
What the keys at the head.
I was old enough to handle it. Yeah. No,
I know. But I mean him being that upset,
it doesn't make sense. Just my dad. Yeah.
That kind of anger is not rational to me,
but that's just like immigrant anger.
Yes.
I remember my dad giving me mad one time
and I fucking, afterwards I was like,
I was like 16
he was mad at me cause I borrow,
I remember I borrowed his golf clubs
and I didn't really know how to golf,
but I started, I was like,
I'm start, you know, doing it.
And it was during like junior,
senior year of high school or something.
And then it was Saturday.
So he went golfing and I didn't put
one of his clubs back in his bag. Fuck.
And he called me like so fucking upset.
And I was like,
and then he came back and got his,
his club out of the bag that I had
put it in and he was like, God dammit.
And like just so upset. And I was
like, and then he left and I was like,
I was like, I was really worked up
about it. And then later on he was like,
I'm sorry, probably terrified
you. I was like, yeah, it's
fucking nine iron man. Yes.
Not that big of the deal. No, it was
upset. I bought a wedge of Amazon.
You know that like multiple, no, but I
just, I go to the range sometimes. Yeah.
It's basically a batting cage for adults.
Like Boberg does that really? Yeah,
I see that on Instagram.
He constantly puts it in a schedule,
30 minutes a day allocated for golf.
He loves it. And even when we did that,
we shot the movie. He would, um,
sometimes play rounds of golf.
Like what'd you have to wait? Like marks
for one a day. Yes. Shit. I was like,
why are we shooting this thing? And
they're like, Mark's playing golf.
And I was like, oh, which by the way,
I was like, make sense to me. Um,
he's a huge movie star. Right?
And then they were like, no,
he's playing golf in another city.
So we wait for his flight to come in.
And I was like, Mike, I still
make sense. That's what I mean.
You know what he likes? Yeah.
Literally nobody complained.
It was like some cities what it is.
Yeah.
They were just like some grip or something
was like, yeah, he's flying background.
I was like, oh, okay. It's
funny. I think my dad was angry.
A lot hard to imagine you're dead, but yet
you have your notes.
She has a foreign,
one time I backed up in the rain and I,
there was a car parked long ways against
a wall and I just fucking smash it to
this guy's car. I was 16 years old
and I just fucked this car. And he is,
that was when he had the maddest at me.
I think fucking up a car will
really bring out dad rage.
So my older sister was in,
by the time she was 18,
double digit car accidents. And the
accident meaning even as simple as,
you know what a gas station, the island
at the gas station sits on the gas pump.
She hit that, she backed
into light poles. She uh,
hit,
she's just like Ping Pong def,
no spatial awareness and just
simply put not a good driver,
you know, speeding tickets, running
stop. Like everything you could fuck up.
She fucked up.
And one time,
I'll never forget they had a um,
in their,
in their bedroom they had basically the
bed on this side of the room and on this
side of the room where the TV was sitting,
the wall was also
like custom cabinets. Like it
was part of the wall. Right.
And My,
my,
my sister got a speeding
ticket called the house,
told my mom and my dad was
opening a drawer in that,
like that wall builtin as my mom told
him and he pulled the whole thing out of
the wall.
Like he removed,
like he was so upset that he was like
fuck and pulled this whole wall off and
she got a hundred. She was
going 105 and a 55. Oh my God.
That's just reckless though. I feel like
I'm one ticket in my whole life. Really.
It wasn't,
it was in like,
it was like the short drive to get to
my parents' house in the development.
It's such the lamest ticket too,
but I did a deferral.
That is where it was for going.
What were you doing?
I was probably doing like 30 and a 25,
but he made it sound like I was doing,
I got a seven over a literal seven over
ticket in South Carolina once she was
like seven. That's a team.
Burbank. That's legit. It's legit.
I had to do community
service and shit like, uh,
so I worked the library for Cup
story. Where the library, Barry Barry,
sorry. There's no, our library
library. Yeah. Oh, sorry.
Yeah, yeah. You're welcome. We're
native speakers here. Sorry. Yeah.
So library. I've been saying it
wrong my whole life just gets,
so there's some other words we might teach
you to pronounce what you had to help
him out.
Oh Shit.
Let me try to think hard as one
x specially like if something's
expensive, special espresso. Espresso.
Espresso, right? Yeah. Do you
want a double espresso? Right.
If you're especially tired and
you should get one similar. Yes.
Similar to something you
gotta be Real Pacific.
Like when you say is you gotta be really
Pacific so you don't confuse people,
you know? Okay. Yeah. Um,
what else? I don't know.
Everything can kind of be a blessing in
disguise when you're blessing this guy.
Yeah. You know, that's a t shirt shop.
So there's all these things you're
obviously learning while you're here.
This is a fresh, um, goat face.
Yeah, go tomorrow. Here's a clip.
Oh,
[inaudible]
comedy central.
That was great because
in my mind I'm like, oh,
he has a club who gave her, I
actually saw the clip or like, oh man,
there's so studious. Like they, they,
they went and they dug it up somehow.
Does he know that? Absolutely. Everybody
has fallen for it. Why would you not know?
I know, I know. It's pretty great.
I have legit gotten clips on
certain things. So, you know,
we talked to the publicist and
they give us a clip, but um,
it's more fun for the person to
be like, Oh shit, here's for sure.
What if we have a sketch like that?
And I'm just sort of like,
that's actually one of my
sayings is we worked really hard.
I work really hard in the vomit.
Why is it called goat? I don't know.
I think when we were brainstorming
as to what the call, the group,
we were just kind of free associating.
And then somebody said, God,
what if it's just like a goat's phase?
And then upon Campbell,
like Ghostface killers.
And that made us laugh.
And then I thought it's because there's
always like goat jokes about that.
You know, the record tryout
fuckers is, you know, there's,
I guess there might be
a Sys of, Oh, I dunno.
Well that's not what we were thinking
about, but it was pretty much the pond.
And then killers got lopped
off and we just stuck with Gus.
He's dealt fuckers instead.
I think that would be a real crowd drug,
don't you think? Oh yeah, I watch
a show called gophers. Yeah.
What about Gulf fucker yourself?
Um, go fuck out your face. Did you guys,
you got you and everybody in this
shot sketches for years? Uh, well,
so what happened was like,
I mean,
the genesis of it was I started
doing standup in Seattle.
So I was doing it for
four years out there.
And while I was getting my degree to
do mechanical engineering at Udab,
God mechanical engineering and Mechanical
Click of a parent's like I wanted to
do theater and shit and
like all this cause I,
I knew I want to do this type of stuff.
And when you're young and you're like,
oh okay I need a theater degree, you
just dumb as shit. You know what I mean?
You go okay I need,
I need to see her degree to do that.
And then luckily my dad is like,
if I'm paying for college I'm not,
I'm not going to pay for a theater
degree. Smart. And then I go,
so I kept on getting more and
more water down. I was like okay,
what about an English degree?
And he's like no I'm not going
to this in front of the way.
Real like dad shit too is like no,
especially immigrant dad too. Cause like,
like you're going to all the time here in
America with patron. Follow your heart,
Dylan, whatever you want to do, find
yourself if that's what you want to do.
Philosophy might be,
I had to talk my parents into it cause
they're like what these philosophy degree
and I was like,
I'm going to go to law school with it
and that's what I lied to them and I was
like,
I'm just going to go to law school.
It's the only way to get into law schools.
And classrooms was thrilled.
I can put together a sentence. They
were just like, you can get any degree.
So then I was like, what about me? What
about film? And they're like, no, no,
it's about real engineering. Core
engineering was the basement pretty much.
And I just knew I wanted it. Your Dad was
not fucking around with this for sure.
It wasn't fucking around. I was
like, I was supposed to be a doctor,
I'm supposed to be a doctor
or like a dentist or a lawyer.
So I was slumming it even
with engineering. But he
would pony up for engineering.
And then I was like,
what type of engineering should I do?
And my best friend across the
street was doing mechanical.
It's like I'll do mechanical,
I'll get to hang out with my
friend more around the university.
So I chose mechanical.
I just wanted to be out in four years.
I didn't want to find myself because
I knew I was, I was trying to do this.
You really knew, you knew then? Yeah,
there's always a means to an end.
So I was like, let me just, you know,
just suck it up, get the degree,
get a job,
and then I could support myself.
I could just apply for jobs and sow cow
and then I can live out here and just do
comedy at night and all that. And so
that's how I got out here. And then, uh,
but it was tough when you move,
where did you just stand up out
here or where did you come from?
When I started here. You
started in la? Yeah. That's,
so that was boggled my mind to start in
La only because I didn't know any better
though. You know what I mean? Okay.
Yeah. I didn't come in here like,
I got to think about that.
When you early on in your comedy career,
how like ignorance is bliss. I tell
people all the time, we're like, gosh,
what I should do. I'm like,
no, don't do that. I mean,
you can't having perspective.
It's crazy to think like I would drive
up from long beach almost every night
after work to do like Mike's in the
valley and Shit. You know what I mean?
I feel like, how are we doing? I mean
like I've known, I've seen you chose for,
it's gotta be over a
decade a while. Yeah. Yeah.
So then the third is when you
moved to from a smaller market,
because I was doing well in Seattle,
he can get up and you're kind of
somebody in in that set of market, same.
But eventually you gotta you gotta leave
and when you go to a saturated place
like New York or La, you're nobody again,
except you know how to write a joke.
You just, you just have like four
years of experience under your belt,
but you're still not getting up. So it
was tough. I was creatively backlog. I'm,
I'm not getting on stage is really,
it's just really hard to get up.
So then I started making
some sketches just uh,
as a way to do that or
just kind of as an outlet.
And so I've had this youtube channel
slash doc 2000 and I would just put videos
up on there while I was
doing standup around town.
And then my buddy Aristotle who went
to USC film school and he has a real,
he's a talented director
and comedian as well.
We became friends and he liked the
videos I was doing. We teamed up,
some of them went viral
and then we decided to,
to add Hassan and awesome, cause it's
more of an angle cause me and him,
it's not really a statement. I'm
Afghan, he's half Greek, half Iranian.
That's not really a thing.
But we were like,
if we add also often a song that's kind
of like Fort Brown dudes who do just
like regular,
just dope sketch,
not about Auntie and uncle shit all
the time because we have very American
sensibilities. We all, we
all grew up here. You know,
I grew up on SNL calling in.
Isn't that interesting though, that
like, uh, I think that's a more, uh,
it's more indicative or like a reflection
of the time now that 15 or 20 years
ago for sure you guys would all
be like, Ma, I talk like this.
Like just like every sketch
would be and now it's like,
Oh yeah,
I've always found just in terms of comedy,
no, I'm the Hashtag [inaudible] place.
And sometimes it's really funny.
I mean I remember that like
someone told me like, uh,
I mean it was a few hours in there.
Like you've never mentioned that
your mom's from Peru. And I'm like,
I must have more power in that though. It
just never, it never occurred to me to,
sure.
It wasn't like,
but also like I grew up like pretty
immersed obviously in American culture and
so I, yeah, it would be disingenuous
to you if you were to doing that. Sure.
That's a part of you.
But if you're playing up that angle,
you would feel weird doing sure.
I figured out way to talk about it
in a way that feels authentic to me.
And I've always been that way as well
to where my sensibilities are very
American. But I do have that gear.
It's always funny first brown second,
like that's, yeah, that's the second part
of my identity. You find American comedy.
So I'm a number one brown
and foreign people, uh,
being disappointed sometimes because
here's what's kind of annoying. Like,
um, I think when it saved my background,
Sam Afghan,
and sometimes I get these messages
back in the day and sometimes still now
they're like, Yo, come to
my university and my MSA,
like it's a Muslim student organization,
come do our event.
And I know that if I did that event,
they would not like what I do.
They have an idea of what I
do or they just see a skin,
skin and comedy and
they add this equation.
And I just know if I were
to do that event, I would,
they would regret it and then I do
comedy or I would have to bend to make
everyone happy. So it's just not a good
thing. And I think just foreigners,
whenever they kind of,
they want you to do the inside joke,
which is like talk about the
Middle Eastern. There were like,
Persians want you to talk
about Persians of course.
But it's such a shallow ceiling.
Yeah.
It's such a quick hit and it's almost as
if you have someone who, who, who's hit,
who's doing well on the mainstream level.
It buoys the people way more than like
doing a wedding here or an MSA event or
some now Rose Festival. Yeah.
So it's something you still
deal with though, right?
People are less so now, because I've had,
you know, I've done some late nights.
I've, I've had, I have like
a special, and you know,
the comedy central thing coming out.
So it's,
the mainstream is kind of
becoming more successful,
whereas when you don't have those
things, they'd be like, Bro, talk about,
you'll talk about this more,
talking about our food more. Yeah.
Way With women comics too. It's
kind of, we're still pigeonholed.
Either you're a mother or you're a slut.
That's so fun.
And it's still not to the point. Or
you're a lesbian, so you're outside of,
of being fuckable and therefore you're,
you're given a little more leeway to
have a voice. But we're still not,
it's still not there where you can be
like, I'm just a person that tells jokes.
I'm not your mom. I'm not the girl
you want to fuck. And I'm not,
and unfuckable dike. So, you know what
I'm saying? There's no room for you.
There's kind of like a flyer.
It's called sluts only,
but uh, but I feel the same
way. Yeah. As a female comedian,
like if you're actually saying something
about the world, it's like, well,
we don't really know what
to do with you just yet.
It might happen another decade.
And then also I've found the,
like the Brown people, they'll
build, I don't know what the term is,
but like the Brown people will,
they'll fuck with you once you get on
the mainstream. They'll be like, yeah,
that's my boy. But it's very hard on
that. There's a select few and it's great.
Like there's nothing more I love then
Afghan fans on the come up who actually
liked what I did.
It's awesome for what it was and are kind
of seeing what's happening now instead
of just like people are though and it's
not unique to one group are obsessed
with hearing about their own. Oh yeah.
Try always. We're tribal by nature, right?
People love inside jokes,
inside baseball stuff. We know.
What's interesting about Netflix is that
when I had a meeting with them to go
over, when I did my first
special there, they're like,
we found out that research shows that
it's not broken down by demographics the
way you think it is.
For instance,
it's not only white women
watching orange is the new black,
you know what I'm saying?
It's not all girls who look
like Piper watching that shit.
Like you'll have like the
black woman in Minnesota,
you'll have a dad in an la watching it,
so it's kind of just proven all of these
years of how they do television shows
and they mark it shows to specific
demos and everything. Like that.
Theory is completely
fucked with Netflix now,
which is great and interesting with
like Black Panther or crazy rich Asians,
right? Oh wait a minute.
People want to see themselves
a revolutionary kind of feels good a
little bit like they proved it right.
People would watch Asian people are gonna
Watch this and you can watch anything.
That's not the point. People would go
see, here's the thing, a white person,
we'll go see a good movie if it's good.
So it's like that going to be like,
what?
There's a bunch of Asians in that and
I was like, if it's good, it ends up,
you know that word of
mouth still will transcend.
Also to just kind of being older now,
even with the rap music man,
number one m and m came out like
how fucking huge to that was. Yes.
It was unheard of.
Do you know how technically proficient
he had to be at rapping to make that
crossover and then look the landscape.
Now you have guys like to catchy or you
have rich, rich Bryan who's an Asian kid.
You can be anything in rap now what?
The cash is terrible,
but I should be sure but like a, or like
the doctor Phil girl, she has a career.
There's no barrier of entry anymore. Girl
would bad baby or something. Yeah, no,
I know. Well now with, with
the, um, with online access,
anybody can throw up anything.
Yeah. It'd be like, Hey,
I mean there's guys with like girls
with the youtube followings from their
fucking iPhone where they now have like
19 million subscribers and it's just
them putting out a video,
not even like a well shot thought
out sketch. Just, you know,
you throw out your personality, people
might respond to it. No, it just happens.
Yeah. You got to realize that people who
did these gate controllers and all that
stuff, it's just monkeys picking
stocks. That's all it is. Yes.
They like to think that
they're tapped into this thing.
But it's great seeing guys even in the
comedy scene where seeing them take off
and I know you didn't fuck
with this person. Yeah.
Because there's a, there's an,
there's a pipeline directly to
the people nowadays. Oh yeah.
You can't deny it and now
they want to get on, you know,
comedy central goat faced Fahim
Anwar, here's a clip off fucker. Yo.
We got a lot of flack over that one,
but I fell on the sword for that. I go,
we're this.
Yeah.
Or I walk.
So I walked away from the wrapper. We
opened the show with her. A rapper.
I remember we did. Yeah. And
that lady that we played earlier,
maybe he'd be interested in hearing
her. Oh yeah. That is Rep. That's right.
I forgot about that. Did you
like rap music? I love rap music.
Wow.
Hollywood madam bitch hoes on the Strip.
Yes.
Politics, politicians,
shit. Hollywood. Madam bit.
Thank Hilda.
The same cohesive song or
first million,
four months,
a hundred back the night count this money.
I mean, she's got a good
rhythm obviously. Yeah.
Where do you find this? We're
lucky in that people said, oh yeah,
I just like to think that you have
on a coffee on it. This is my jam.
It's gonna be a long night adult
performer that that rapper does.
Other things. I wouldn't have
been able to tell. Just, yeah,
we looked it up and a lot of
anal clips. Yeah. Are you a,
is that your kind of go to the anal? When
you, when you're doing a search, is that,
is it mostly and you know her? No, no, no,
no. It's just rapping. Do you have lanes,
lanes of a hardcore that you like to use
is Tom doesn't even know you that well.
Come on man and dad are going to
listen to this. They're not Muslim.
He doesn't do that shit all over my face.
Okay,
so um,
we have a fun segment.
We like to call drugs or mental illness
and we play you a video and you tell us
whether you think this person is high
or mentally ill. Okay, here we go.
It's a hard game.
Hello?
There is a death curse.
They place on the leader on
credit of Iran. It got it.
And the toe. Yeah. I told her,
I'm going to say mentally,
I think you're right. Yeah.
For
starts. How do we know? We
never know or any kind of card.
It's just a gut feeling in the room.
The consensus
or I can drop the price to $10,000
that times after like a
few set of few episodes,
Dr drew will come in and he's really
good at spotting things that he'll be
killed. He'll, yeah, he'll look
at even breathing patterns.
It looks at the colors and the
eye, the skinny. He'll be like,
well that's pretty much definitely math.
And like,
he's just really good for us that we have.
We been like,
whoa. Like we had no idea this, by
the way. We have to show him this guy.
Which forest gang of this guy. Oh, this
guy. Oh yeah. Where's my list? Shit. Yeah,
it's called our, we call it the two drew
list, so we make sure that he sees, oh,
okay. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So, um,
yeah, but this guy, I dunno,
I think we're definitely,
you'd want to do anything. And I did.
You can contact with a youtube services.
I'll check email that way you can.
I'm glad it had provided surgeon
or removing the curse. A curse.
So is that, sounds like there's a curse
though on the ayatollah and the uh,
and the president of Iran. This is
just a put Iran president. Yeah. Curse.
And that was sent to you?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Um, here's another one. Okay. I don't
know if this is the same guy or not,
but it says drugs or mental
illness. Oh Shit. Oh, same guy.
Sorry.
Death curse.
Maybe it's high on the tone
for anyone who's a member of
and the Taliban. Okay. I think we all
agree something's wrong though, right?
Yeah. Brad is Walthill. Yeah, yeah.
Uh, Shit. Did you know that they're, well
remember that porn we played that was,
um, sit down Hussein? The
porn replayed. Oh yeah,
sorry. Yeah, it was like
Taliban porn. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. When they rated than any half,
like a tons of hard drive of porn. Yes.
Yes he did. He did. But this was like, um,
let me see if I can, uh,
if I can pull this up.
The Taliban porn, well, this
might get him all worked up.
I don't know if you want to see
if this had, you know, these guys.
Here we go. Here we go. Hold on.
US military forces are,
are on their way from
what I understand and no,
hold on.
Is this from Ghostface or is
this is on the cutting room floor.
This was cut for time.
Yeah.
It seems that time is running out for
a summer bin Laden and soon he'll fall
into the hands of the Northern
Alliance and a special forces.
Oh,
by the way,
I think if you would have
done this segment on a goat
phase [inaudible] big head.
I get thick monster numbers.
Especially if you've got this,
you feel like we might alienate our bays.
Oh
No. Here we go. Who is the end
of this like you gotta really?
Where do you get this actor
is what I want to know.
Oh, uh, this is, I'm like,
this is a craigslist ad.
Like if you're the brown dude,
you know what I mean?
Now, none of the higher ups that
kind of sent to say anything,
they're just like, there's,
there's humor here.
Uh,
I'm trying to get me in trouble. I'm
sorry to get knifed on the side. Wow.
Um,
I like Halloween.
They're like Veronica cane in Afghanistan,
like the whole country
and they're like, uh, people as me. Yeah.
Where do you think they actually at
Northridge. Yeah, we did. We did, uh,
did that whiskey, tango, Foxtrot,
that Tina Fey movie and we did it in New
Mexico and so New Mexico just doubles
for Afghanistan I guess. Oh yeah.
They're shooting everything. Yeah.
It was in Albuquerque and Santa Fe.
Did that come out? Wait, is that,
it was like two years ago that,
yeah. Wow. Um, we've been really,
really on one with Garth
Brooks the last few weeks.
Months. Really. Um, you
like him? He's all right. I,
I mean I'm not a huge,
I know of him. Yeah.
Is he still like really big or
is it all about, oh, he's huge.
He's beyond any things. You like the
Drake of country music? Yes ma'am. Better.
Bigger. Right. But he's still
flying on harnesses, like
over the audience. I Dunno.
He's doing it. He's still do Chris'
Games. No, no. That's when I tapped out.
Chris Gaines had the commercials
have been airing that um,
his Notre Dame show is going to be,
is going to come out. Oh, okay. Yeah.
So that's a big ass stadium tour.
The big ass stadium tour of which
Notre Dame was the first stop,
first concert ever in Notre Dame stadium
cheese and now he's just going to do
nothing but stadiums. He's
there. He's way there bro.
All stadium too.
It was supposed to be,
it was going to be a college tour because
of the cities, how they worked out.
Just going to be some professional
stadiums and then as well,
so we're just gonna keep
it at the staging tool.
But this one is going to be so special,
so rare,
so far apart. We'll do
about, we'll do this,
we'll do probably 10 to
12 a year for three years.
Jesus, 10 to 12 a year for three
years. It's defensive body language.
I don't guard. It's like he doesn't
need it. It's, he doesn't need it.
And it's like he doesn't dress up for
his press conference either. In visual,
very unique. There's
body language. We are.
You don't categorize me, Ron, did you have
like Tommy from the store? I don't know.
Did you ever interact?
Yeah.
Get a little Tommy vibe with the
arms crossed with indifference to,
by the way, this is the stadium tour.
Like why is he disgusted by his own tour?
This is probably the fifth
or six different video
months apart that we've won
where he's wearing that same app you
felt he just wears that shirt shirt.
Can I tell you what I figured out what?
I know why he's God damn weird.
Why I'm being serious.
I think he might be slightly
autistic or Asperger's.
I'm serious. Now think about my fucking
theory. I can buy into it because a,
he mimics a lot of what he sees as
being normal human behavior and that's
probably why he's not reading well
on social media cause he's not,
he's really not relatable and all of
his interviews are fucking weird and a
little ass burglary, but he's really good
at what he does. He's pretty meticulous,
right? Yeah. I'm going to go like a
dash of Asperger's. I like your theory.
I'm serious. A Sasha just, he's fun. He's
highly, I'm not saying he's like full,
just a dash of Asperger. I'm going to
go to the line. Yeah, I think he is.
Could be,
let's see if this gets me
more weird, scared,
nervous. All good things.
We'll say this is the whole diverse
going to be like another day to handle.
This is the most work that I've ever met.
Well isn't that a weird thing to say?
It's weird, but that's what I'm saying is,
but it's an,
it's a weird offshoot of aspergers where
it's like with a dash of confidence or
I've got a heap of confidence.
Well, there's a little
Asperger's with confidence.
Yes, there are performers
and habit though, is that
are really successful. Yes.
So this is a press conference about
your tour where you're like, I'm scared.
I'm nervous, I'm excited. Honestly,
I don't know if I'll be able to
handle my own tour. Like he just said,
if it goes like he just said it.
He's like,
if the rest of the tour goes like this,
I honestly don't know if I'll
be able to do it. What? Like,
what are you talking about? You're going
to be able to do your own tour. Yeah,
because it's just too much.
Well then don't fucking
something towards secure though.
And they doubled down the
other way, right? Yeah. Yeah.
That's why I think is really
happening. I think it's fake. I'm so,
I don't know all solar.
What's going to go this?
This is the most that I've ever worked,
but so most time I've
ever put into anything,
he runs the of Ricky
Gervais' for the office.
The character? Yes.
David Brent. Yeah. Yeah.
They want to be the best matter.
Like you walk in there.
That's a wonderful Spanish dance.
I'm doctor to her. Watch him. Yeah.
Give it to him.
Let them know that you care.
Let them know that you're singing just to
them. And that is easy in a honky talk.
And it became easy in an arena and that's
what our whole pulling becomes easy in
a stadium. He's about to cry right away
and they can feel like their front row.
Oh boy, that's he's, he's getting
emotional there about putting on the show.
That'll change your life. It's weird, man.
It is weird. Yeah, it sounds going on.
We are.
Dr Drew has to watch what's going on.
As He's thinking about all the bodies
he's got stacked in fucking graves on is
and is 100% he's probably killed two,
300 people in his life. It's a
good cover. Yeah. No, I think so.
I want to go with it.
Just a dash Asperger's.
Did you shop for Black Friday?
I know you've always known to me that
you're a huge shopper line overnight.
Do that. What's the point?
You know what I mean?
So I think the only people who do it, it's
like if it's a ritual like the family,
all right, after we eat Turkey we, this
is the thing we've been doing for years.
Yeah. Does anybody need to save
that much money? Just for a thing.
I think some people really can't stand
the thought that they might not get the
deal that somebody else got.
And those are the people.
It's actually a number of them.
Don't you value value your over 50 bucks?
I do. Those people don't. And
then what about cyber Monday?
Just have it delivered to your house?
Yeah, well, I had a friend that's like my,
my mother and I do it every year.
Like you were saying,
we take turns standing in line, so
it's like a fun thing. I don't know.
It sounds like torture to me.
Sounds like the worst thing ever.
Especially if you can't get a refund.
It goes to your debit card directly.
I'm just talking.
I will see you.
I'm not putting it on youtube.
I'm document.
Yeah, sure. That is perfectly fine.
You don't want to be recorded.
There's no way they can afford
an attorney. It's on youtube now.
If he's asking for the $50 back or
whatever, she can't clearly can't afford.
Attorneys are very expensive,
I guess Ross.
Oh well that's not even there
anymore. How good. The detective,
I like how they're doing in
front of the baby. That's nice.
I hope everyone fucking job.
How do you feel about Sears going out of
business and then I'm calling see your
stupid.
Okay,
awesome.
These are, these people are really
giving white people a bad name.
I kind of say this is a very
white kind of feel to it.
White trash though. Hey, to be clear, I
don't know if I would call them morning.
Yeah, there's different levels of of
white. I mean, you know what I mean?
I was trying to be nice to them.
Oh, I'm not terrible people.
These are garbage people.
Do you think they're the same family
or friends or like four different white
wanting to get a refund.
That's the crew they went through.
They needed a backup. They go bring
your baby. Oh Yeah, God, the baby needs.
Could you imagine being that
baby? It sucks. It's terrible.
Isn't your shitty family?
Dammit. I know what this is over.
Also like what the item is,
you know?
What do you think the cost is of the item?
What are the squabbling over 20 bucks?
It's probably, it's less than a
hundred yeah, for sure. Yeah. Yeah.
The real game is like,
is it $26 a good price is right game.
That's just sort of like
just the white trash
trash off
Clark.
Oh Shit. Now she's calling
somebody out on their job.
Please tell us the amount if it's fucking,
did you get your money?
What do you mean before I'm knock it out.
Knock it out.
She'd have to kick it up though.
My hands are tied up.
There was a Sears mastercard application.
If you're interested. Some not.
That's something you would want.
I have a pair of pants that I bought
from Sears and I can't return them now.
Oh no where to return.
There's no CEO then Kmart just shut down.
The camera's been gone for a long
time. No, you didn't know this.
Kmart just shoot down, uh, one of their
stores last week and it was a big deal.
Are they still around? I thought
they were done. They are.
Do you remember what you have?
They have been closing down
slowly. Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
Here's, has been doing that too. And
now I think they're finally like, yeah,
what's the cane toys r us. Oh
man, that dude's gone. That hurts.
Cause I remember that was
such a big part of my life.
I remember I would get such a rush.
I'm going to toys r us and picking
an intender game. Do you remember?
Like they would have it right there
and they'd be like, get it for you.
You'll never experience that again.
It's just weird.
There's like things about being older
where technology advances. Like,
like even buying a CD,
I remember you would go into circuit
city or best buy or future shop or,
and you'd have to walk by washing machines
and shit to actually get a CD. Yeah.
[inaudible] in the cellophane and no one,
no one that now just on your phone it
would know like the whole, the ritual,
the ritual of being dropped off,
you know. And then having, man,
there was a point where cds were like
getting like it was like 1699 they were
getting to try see pretty pricey.
But you would seek out and then
to hold it like the actual,
and it had that security, you know
clamp. Yeah. Have to get it unlocked.
I love that Rachel. Yeah,
it was really fun. And,
and it always comes out on Tuesdays.
Oh for like we have new
releases or releases. Yeah.
But in hindsight you can understand why
the music industry was going to fuck
cause they're just bilking us
for so long. Oh, cds are what?
17 2121 bucks and there's three good
songs on it. Oh my God. Now we pay what,
like 10 bucks a month for Spotify?
Yeah. Every song in the universe.
Not that mansion.
The uh,
what you were the actual
cost of producing that,
that actual item. Was it like pennies?
Yeah. So you were just, you know,
I mean obviously you're not paying just
for the whole day paying for the content,
but they're really word robbing us.
But you've got the booklet and you gotta
throw quit lyrics, read the lyrics,
you're fine.
I liked her albums.
Even you could do your homework on the
album cover. Yeah, I know your shit. Yeah.
Everyone, all the rappers started doing
double disc and triple discs. Dean.
And I thought it was so great as a kid.
Like, yeah. More content, like, yeah,
more songs. But in hindsight
you're like, do some editing.
Not all of these are the youngers.
No water. Garbage on here.
So we've been talking all this, uh, Garth
stuff. We've got an email that said, um,
I brought up Garth Brooks when I saw
an advertisement for one of his shows
during Thanksgiving,
which was obviously the,
the big and the Notre Dame
one in an attempt to expose
how crazy Garth Garth was
to my relatives.
Instead,
I got roped into a six hour
conversation with my grandfather,
which led me to watching two full length
live Garth concerts in both New York
City in Dublin as well as
listening to for Garth albums.
I tried to tell my grandpa they only
know Garth from your mom's house,
but now he thinks I'm a
huge fan of country music.
And especially with Garth quite
literally until my grandfather dies,
I will now need to pretend I left
guard. So in short, fuck you.
High insight Stephen.
Yeah. Nice. That's good.
That is good stuff. Fuck man. Well
that's kind of Nice. A stronger bond.
But now he has to keep this
facade of living Garth Brooks.
So he was probably like, have you seen
Garth Brooks? And His grandpa was like,
you like him too? He's like, well, yeah.
And then it just went downhill from there.
God Damn. Um, here's a, Oh,
a scrump solution. Oh, okay.
Um, when you date you're dating,
do you have a, you're trying to,
you're about to be on big TV show
on comedy central and we'll see.
You can start getting some of
those hot submissions like I get,
do we talk about this on the show yet?
About
five years or something about the
upright, right before we hit record. Uh,
we were at dinner the other
night and Christina goes, um,
we're having a dinner with a couple
and then, uh, they said that, you know,
the wife said that she sees emails for
her husband and then Christina goes,
Tom, do you get hit up a lot?
Like A, now that you're, you know,
touring and put out specials, like to our
chip just hitting on you. I'm like, yeah,
about once every five years I'll get
an email or some message from a woman.
It'll look like I'm a woman.
Um,
but like dude's weekly will be like,
you're so hot and a,
and I'll be like, cool. Like, you
know, Instagram stuff, they'll be like,
great special. It doesn't hurt
that you're easy on the eyes.
Less of a filter with, with gay guys.
Yeah, of course. I'll get that too.
And then also I think like black chicks
aren't into me as well. Really Nice.
I don't know what that, what
it is. Why that demo? Yeah.
Do you maybe I'm like a light skin
black Swizz beats or something.
Have you ever hooked up with a fan? Like
somebody who messaged you, like, um,
you know, you're hilarious and then
meet them? No, never. Wow. Yeah.
Did you get, you're going to do
it now I assume. I don't know.
So you never even like entertain the idea,
like let's say sounds fun.
You know what I mean? But like
Instagram, Instagram is photos.
Like somebody goes like, oh my God,
you're so funny. And you see it's a girl.
You've never been like, she,
I'll be, I'll be, I'll, I'll
look. Yeah. And then nothing,
no. Pursue it at all. Uh, well sometimes
logistically we just sort of like,
it's like when a 13 year old girl says
marry me Bieber or whatever. Right.
You know, like it seems so
emotionally mature. Thanks.
This is mechanical engineering, so
that'd be maybe a to practical. Yeah.
You're like, well look,
you live too far away.
Also, I've thought about this too,
like as you get older, like in your,
in your 20s like you'll, you'll chase
the girl. Everyone would be like, hey,
we're at this word, this bar, come here
and do yoga. We're in Riverside or animal.
We would like,
you just follow them everywhere.
You don't think about anything and then
when you get older you just kind of like,
you can do the math or they're like, hey,
we're at this bar and then your mind,
okay, it's one 30 she's around
a town with four of her friends.
Like you can just crunch the numbers
and you're like, I'm not doing,
this is another, yeah, this is nothing
you're describing me at my thinking.
At 21 I was like,
I'm tired.
I just, that's what I
always say. I was like,
I never pursued anything that didn't
just kind of show up. Yeah. Yeah.
I just wasn't into effort. I'd be like,
what? We're going to go to another place?
Yeah. Terrible. Yeah, it's terrible. It's
probably why you and I lasted and we,
I mean I basically was like,
just kind of like over, we'll
go to a bar. Yeah. Those,
those are good at hitting balls that
are caught to me but I'm not, yeah,
I'm not yo, what up girl? Who'd
you get into? I love your face.
Probably
Margaret. Cause he know that your
girl likes you already faces so hot.
But that,
but that's good cause you don't wanna
have to fight some chick to likeyeah.
It's terrible.
Would you consider possibly um,
putting out like a, a video like
this to like, just to get the ladies,
you know what I mean?
Hi Baby.
Oh this great sad day.
I've been looking at your picture.
So low bay and they met
and they magnify my eyes.
Bay.
Yeah.
I'm it to a telescope when
I see your page. Nice.
You feel so good to meet bay. They will
not meet you. Are you talking to me?
I want you to milk me like hot chocolate
and candy and not with high bro.
Well,
we cool.
See, I picture you like that.
Like that's my game by a yeah.
I said it's the wrong some aviators.
I turned into a telescope when I see you,
I metlife had,
he thought that was like a hot bar right
there. Like a girl's gonna be like,
damn a telescope.
That was Gus sexy as hell sense.
Tell us when I see you. I turned
into a telescope. What did that mean?
Say That I really look at your
picture when I see it, but uh,
came out the way he put it, which is kind
of cooler. What are you going to go for?
Drugs or mental illness on that one.
I think that's just his death swag.
That's too much swag. I thought, oh,
I'm going to go drunk. Old School
Alcohol Abuse Pot. Yeah. Okay.
Double. Yeah, it's a lot of
drugs and alcohol I think might
be a little booze in there.
Yeah. I'm here is a, uh,
a message though about this called
the scrum solution. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
So like when you do data girl though,
you ever eat her?
Ask her to eat your scrum or something
like that. Okay. Um, this one says,
Hey Hitler's,
I may have a solution to getting
Christina over her scrum eating no phobia
to decide triple d sled girlfriend and
I have been together for three years now
and never once had she ate or
even offered to eat my scrum.
Obviously I was very frustrated at how
inconsiderate and rude she was being as I
am as well.
Finally,
the strategy that worked for me was
to no longer bring up my browns.
The discussion of size, shape, smell,
and frequently is now off the table.
One month ago today,
while she and I were practicing
for her 16th birthday,
I kept telling her to sniff those balls,
but she kept wandering further south.
I finally gave in and I let her eat my
scrum for the first time and it was truly
a life changing experience.
It has now become a frequent event that
she will eat my scrum and then I give
her her reward. Okay. Anyway, it's
a real Sophie's choice. Good luck.
Piss on me and beat me. Chad w that's a
nice message. Chat. Thanks so much for,
so what do you think? Maybe we stopped
talking about Brown and then you know,
your tongue launder south. I would rather
talk about Brown and enjoy the talks.
Then eat your scrum.
Do you know what I mean?
Like talking about what I'd prefer w
how much joy scrum taint or well yeah,
that's a little further back. Yeah.
Am I going to do it? It's never happy.
Whole adjacent. Yeah. I see. Yeah.
I mean, will you give her a
little encouragement? Know what?
It's really not my place.
That's kind of let's you guys
let him have a do it for him.
I have a question for you. Let's say
you've just eaten a bunch of Afghan food,
right? Right. This is a great
segue from scrum. Does that,
this is like a free associate. Yeah.
Speaking of scrum, Afghan food,
tell me about it.
You've just had a big play of mom's
cooking and then she was like,
give us a company or would it be,
uh, it's like rice and meat based,
I would guess.
Sort of if I had to say what it is you
maybe like chicken and rice or like
playing with rice sauce or something.
I was going to core mine,
which is kind of like, um, like a curry.
Yeah. Okay. There you go. Perfect. Okay,
so you've had your curry and it's the
morning and your dump dump dumping and
it's a messy brown and you go
to wipe and you just go like,
you know when you wipe and you're
like, oh boy, this is a disaster.
Like this is going to require
a lot of cleanup. Right.
So we have a total wash let,
have you ever used that a washlet it's
like sprays water and you're just like a
day. Yeah. But my question
is what do you do on that?
Like do you just go to shower? What do
you mean? Like you wipe, wipe, wipe,
but the Brown keeps coming down.
It never ending wipe scenario.
But how come when you go in the shower
and then you wash it with soap and water?
The never ending wipe stops. What's your
theory? He had a lot of cascading water.
So, although you visually cannot
see all the, it's, it's working.
You think it's just the
cleaning of the browns,
the water cascading done your bowl.
That's my guess. I do. I do a toilet
paper. Baby Wipe Combo. You do?
Oh yeah. But how do you feel about
that, that the day that, that,
that I'm not there yet. Um, yeah. I
have no idea how I would feel about it.
I've never done it. Now where would
I go? I don't have fancy friends.
Do you have to bag a brown right now?
No. I wish that's very flattering.
Like no one would ever say, do you have
to please take a shit in my toilet? Oh,
I would normally, normally it's
like, take a shit in the lobby.
Don't do to my hotel room.
But you guys are the opposite.
He was a little go outside. Tell me
when you want to do a dump. Yeah.
We encourage people to Brown here. Yeah,
we do. Wow. You're, you're a rare breed.
Yeah. You're like the only people who are
like that. What is your take by the way?
Your, yeah. Your gut reaction.
Is this horrible or hilarious.
Oh,
come on.
You're sick inside too. If
he's okay. He's not okay.
Yeah, I see a smile from you.
The sound of him yelling at
the wellbeing of the sounds are funny.
Most of the,
yeah.
That's funny. Yeah. There's
a look at the slow Mo.
Oh Wow. Oh, oh, that's not good.
Fuck.
Oh,
the scream is funny. That
was funny. In slow Mo. Yeah,
you're right. Real time. Yeah.
Brutal. I mean that definitely
hurt. That hurt. Like hell
man.
He goes and him going, oh yeah.
Just the realization of impending doom.
Yeah. At the apex is very comical.
There's also like, uh, like the,
what are you landed on this rate?
Like when he hit the railing,
that probably broke something. And
then when he, when he fell here,
um, it's an additional hit, you know,
like before he died, it definitely,
he's dead. That's what it says
here. He says he died. Oh, stop.
He was screaming. She was like, what?
Lay in bed at night time. You just
have this on a loop and you're here by
video. I don't know how to dig it up, but
there's this like little kid on a bike.
He's like learning how to ride a bike
for the first time. And he's like,
hello, hello. And then he's like,
there's a tree right there. And he goes,
no. He goes, ah, ah.
And then he hits the tree.
It's the funniest shit.
I laughed so hard at that as
much as just him saying, okay,
hmm.
I like, I mean there's certain sounds that
are just funny. I'm like, no, please. No
thanks.
Oh,
what happened?
Huh?
Write it out. Oh, no
learning man. You learn to play the first
part again. Did he just run into him?
No, he's backing up, but you know,
we've got to ease off the clutch.
Just give it a little bit more man.
That back it up.
Not too long.
It sounds like a threat. The Reb.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Well he's like,
there's more where that comes.
Yeah. But then there's this funny
stuff like that sending out funny.
It's not okay. Yeah, no, he's
okay. He's alive. He's fine.
Actually,
we learned that he was fine.
It was a big story in Taiwan when it
happened. Right? Seriously? No, no,
I swear to you. Oh, well how, yeah.
How's that? A big story. Well,
because it went viral and it was,
it was in Taiwan,
so then it was in the news and
people were like, is this guy dead?
There is like shattered. Turned
out. He just said bruises. Oh yeah.
This wasn't because uh, some people
thought for sure the legs were amputated,
but no, you weren't. Yeah. Yeah. It makes
me feel better about it. Yeah. Yeah.
You laugh pretty hard. Be Honest. That's
how he laugh. No, I'm saying you left.
He enjoyed that.
Christine has always like weirded out
when I show it to people because I'm a
mother and I hate seeing people
getting hurt. Men are destroyers,
women are creators. You know what
I mean? Yeah. They create life.
You guys fucking kill each
other. Yeah. Serial killers.
All male. Mostly murderers.
Male mostly. Hmm. That's a good
point. It's fucking theory.
Would you rather sit through 24 hour
performance of here's what I'm going to
give you choices. Okay. Okay.
This,
so it's just this 24 hours.
This Yoko Ono,
I,
I'm going to kill myself.
Okay. So do you want 24 hours of that? No.
Or 24 for 24 hours in a row.
Oh fuck.
This is a vocal performer.
24 I'm going to go this guy.
Or it's annoying.
Oh, so far they're both a
very annoying or 24 hours.
Yours.
Jesus Christ.
How does he have this large
of an audience? Oh, oh yeah,
this guy moves tickets.
This, I really sells tickets.
I mean, I think as a comedian,
when you watch your stuff and you
see people busting up in the crowd,
don't you die inside? Yes. Dykes a
sour and go into a homicidal rage.
Yeah. Yeah. And be like,
wow, what an amazing skill.
It's so dumb.
So yeah, which is, give
me the order of worst.
The worst one,
all the way down.
I'm going to go to, it's tough
between the screaming guy. Yeah.
And this last one with
the mustache as the worst,
I think so over the drumming lady
drumming. Or you don't have to look at
them. You know what a drum sounds like.
It's very passive.
This is performance running.
It's not even real drumming. It's
like you don't have to see their eyes.
It's like a bear rummaging
through the trash. Look at him
watching like it's a real thing.
Like yes,
this is our crazy piece of shit.
I know you guys are watching the stupid,
this is so dumb.
People buy into this,
we'll get this guy
analyzing it like it's real.
Yes, art. Yeah. That's cool.
You think this is really hard.
See I suppose cause I didn't see him
go that violent on the drum and that's
really annoying. I thought it was
just sort of like, is it a girl?
I think it's a guy. Mike gone hair
guy. Yeah. We Egos on these three.
I think middle, middle. I definitely, I
can't do, that's just too great voice guy,
that guy. Okay, so that's the worst.
That's the worst for me. Yeah. Yeah.
That's pretty back in place.
Go ahead.
It's hard.
It's hard to
Ah,
oh
24 hours. What if they did like a
watch the throne tour. This guy,
the last guy. People minds
are blown. Oh Holy Shit.
As in suicidally boring.
Yeah.
Age that just like floats over
everybody like Kanye, you know. See I'm,
I'm struggling here because
I feel like the drummer,
I want to punch straight in the fucking
mouth for thinking that he's putting on
a show. Yeah. This guy,
I realize he does a specific thing and
in its own weird way he can actually do
this bullshit.
Well, but I want, I want him dead
100%. So those are the struggle for me.
Cause now I, now that I see all
three together, the hand boning guys,
definitely the most tolerable,
the clapping guy. I agree with
you. But here's the thing,
if a heme brings up an excellent
point is the rage. And um, I would,
I imagine myself watching
him do this horse shit,
people laughing and the torture of the
audience enjoying that might set me off
even more than the drumming
and the screaming. So there's
two layers to it, right?
It's drumming is just, everyone's
just get through this, right?
But then the emotional component
to the stupid ham boning,
it adds another layer of triggering
layer for me. So I'm going to go,
I'm going to go number one
on the hand boning guy.
It pisses me. This is the most
offensive second place, the drummer,
third way, this is fine. This, this
is just a homeless guy in my mind.
You know what I mean? Take a homeless
guy on an alley. It's like big deal.
Some guy on the subways is crazy.
24 hours though. That's hey,
but the ham Boehner would make me go.
Not really any price.
I think the drummer I hate the most.
I think I hate the drum or the most,
the drummer.
I think so.
We're always fucking pointing out how
nasty and inappropriate people are in
different scenarios, sometimes in
public. So we got an email said,
I recently started listening to the
podcast and I've been listening glassing
through the back catalog
back in episode three 98.
Are you talking about sandals
specifically? Stinky, funky,
ugly ass Birkenstocks.
I think that's the official
shoe of Seattle. Right? Um,
I don't know yet if you got the blowback
you were expecting from the low and
loose dirt Burke wears,
but I'm 100% with you.
Totally smelling your
ass hole on this one.
I don't know if you classy celebrity
country club folk or anything like the
modest non-binary Zur from Canada,
but I see some real nasty ass pictures.
People post in swap and sell groups on
Facebook of their like new and worn once
Sandra's wow.
Some of them look like the person may
have been burned to death wearing them
leaving the imprint. Oh,
on there for eternity.
I took a few screenshots to share with
you, but now or to share with my brother.
Now I'm going to share them with you.
Keep those jeans high and tight in
those purples. Big and mushy. Kevin.
People are fucking, oh, like,
oh look only worn two times.
No Bitch 22 times.
That's bullshit.
Ah,
this is, how should those costs
new? That's what I'm saying.
Hundred dollars may really are 100 bucks.
I think they're pretty well.
Maybe she loves their
Burke has worn twice.
Twice.
Yeah.
Uh, no, barely warm.
My feet change sizes,
I can't wear them anymore.
Ah,
uh,
I think people's criterion for barely
worn the Birkenstock community is a bit
different.
These are totally faded and look
at the indentations of the toes,
you know, is there like a park?
Is there a market for that?
Like these are 10 bucks. These, this
person was like, I've got to get some,
I have friends and stuff.
We'll have raw denim jeans that were worn
by a Japanese guy for like two years.
Like Bobby Lee will do
that where he'll pay.
There's Niggas company where like you're
paying a premium for people having worn
them in for you. Oh, that's
funny. So pants you can
handle, but like that's funny.
I think some of them pants. I don't want
anyone, I don't want to a pants either.
Yeah. So here we go. Birkenstocks
are expensive. $139 Oh shit.
$100. This is a high ticket item.
You know why people would buy them.
You just feel like those aren't
for me. Yeah. Get the rung below.
Birkenstock a hundred dollar
shoes. Yeah. I mean, I've,
I've wanted nice shit that I
couldn't get and I was like, oh,
I guess I just won't buy that. We're
just, wait, wait a little bit. Save up.
You know, I'd be like, I have $40
now, so I'll just put that aside.
How funny it was. If they want to stunt
on there, like granola friends, they go,
oh nice dude. Nice new Birkenstocks. Yeah.
But in the back of your mind, you know,
they're second hand. That's the
only reason to get them second hand.
Somebody wore these to a festival already
and I'm fucking flexing on these fools
right now. I'm so torn on the
Birkenstock because on the one hand,
I imagine the comfort,
you must feel wearing them.
They do look like be ultimate comfort.
Why are they so grading? I don't get it.
I Dunno. Sure. They're
flexible. Your foot is free.
I think part of what's amazing about them,
like I mean levels of it is number one,
the ease of putting on and taking off.
Is that any sandal? Yeah, but I mean
like I'm just saying this one component.
Right. Okay. And then the,
I talked to a couple of
Birkenstocks fanatics who were like,
they are so unbelievably comfortable,
and you wear through them,
like they're still comfortable, but you
eventually wear through them. You know,
you have to re up those, those shoes,
I guess fairly often. But they're like,
I know a couple people that are
obsessed with them. They're like,
they really love them. I never, I just,
my problem is they're so unfashionable
and I'm not a big fashion Easter,
but there's so unfuckable
like you're just, Oh,
you're really giving into not having
sat on like that. Yeah. I don't like it.
I like to look, I mean, I've
seen you wear the most days,
but I think that's just part of
my stage persona. Yeah. Yeah. Um,
I compost on stage too. It's kind of a new
thing that I'm doing. It takes a while,
but I had a landlady that composted and
she get mad if I didn't put my table
scraps on her compost heap. I'm just
not going to do that. He's not doing it.
Then she puts your trash and your
thing on. What's wrong, Tom? Sorry,
I'm just looking at something
that a message came in. All
right. Um, what about, uh,
dates? Are you doing any road dates coming
up? I'm a teammate with Neil. You know,
I was opening for him on his
tour. Oh yeah. How'd it go?
Here we go tour. Good. Uh,
we took November
off, so we're back on December.
I think we're doing la,
Denver and San Diego and
Arizona. All right. Yeah.
And then you have this thing around La.
I don't have anything on the books yet,
but I think the promo goat face, I might
get some road dates set up. Great Grace.
And let's encourage everybody a two,
if you're listening to this episode
as it comes out, a watch goat Phelps,
that'd be great. Comedy
Central Comedy Central. Um,
10:00 PM November 27th. Wonderful.
Yeah. And then I have a special called,
there's no business like show
business coming central licenses.
So I think he watched it for free on their
website and it's also on Amazon prime.
I love Amazon prime. Yeah. Good. Then I
have a podcast too called Humana or dance.
Our
dance.
You've put out some hilarious videos.
You know what,
like one of the first times we chatted,
um,
it was in the backstage of the main
room at the comedy store. Yeah.
And you are in your space. I didn't want
to bother you. And you're like, oh, I saw,
I saw, I don't dance that Brent wine, Bach
short film. And you were really into it.
And that was really cool
for me because I did an,
you don't know who watches watch that
came your way and people just Google that.
It's on Vimeo. Yeah. It's called,
I don't dance. I love Brent.
He's such a weird comedy brain is man.
There's no one like him.
No Buddy. Um, well please support
for him and uh, thanks for coming.
Genius or anything else you want
to add? No, I love you. I love you.
Thanks again for coming in and are having,
we should edit.
Here's a young Patriot on a scrum dog
millionaire produced by Dj j p sounds.
We'll see you guys next.
[inaudible]
okay.